[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débats de reportage et d'expertise
comme tous les soirs sur Public Sénat
vous le savez la promesse est dans le
titre donné du sens à l'actualité vous
proposez des clés de compréhension des
mutations de nos sociétés voici le
sommaire de ceux de novembre un titre de
séjour pour les métiers en tension d'un
côté et la volonté de l'autre de rendre
je le cite impossible la vie des
étrangers soumis à une obligation de
quitter le territoire c'est le en même
temps macroniste appliqué à
l'immigration cette loi portée par les
ministres du travail et de l'Intérieur
peut-elle trouver une majorité au
Parlement ce sera notre premier débat et
puis dans 45 minutes direction l'Arménie
l'Arménie attaquée par son voisin
laserbaïdjan et qui tente de mobiliser
la communauté internationale mais dans
l'équation il y a une donnée qui freine
l'indignation et les sanctions le gaz
venu de Bakou et dont l'Europe a
cruellement besoin
a besoin de gaz elle signe des accords
gaziers avec laserbaïdian l'Azerbaïdjan
qui envahit il y a quelques il y a
quelques jours et qui violent les
frontières de l'Arménie
l'Arménie l'autre guerre c'est
l'histoire d'un petit pays chrétien aux
prises avec ses puissants voisins turcs
et russes que l'on vous racontera tout à
l'heure mais d'abord donc ce projet de
loi immigration présentée par Olivier
dussoft et Gérald Darmanin c'est
Jonathan Dupriez qui nous a redresse les
grandes lignes
le gouvernement vant un projet de loi
équilibré Gérald Darmanin et Olivier
dussobe ont précisé les contours de la
future loi asile immigration une loi qui
devrait aussi les entre durcissement des
expulsions d'un côté et maintendue pour
les travailleurs immigrés de l'autre si
je devais résumer je dirais qu'on doit
désormais être méchant avec les méchants
et gentils avec les gentils parmi les
principales mesures avancées rendre plus
efficace les obligations de quitter le
territoire français les fameuses au qtf
qui permettent d'expulser les étrangers
en situation irrégulière la France ont
des livres 120 000 chaque année mais en
exécute moins de 10%. Gérald Darmanin
préconise de placer les personnes visées
par une OCC dans le fichier des
personnes recherchées mais certains
parlementaires doutent de l'utilité
d'une telle mesure le fichier des
personnes recherchées ce sont
principalement enfin pour
essentiellement pour des gens qui ont
commis des infractions ou qui ont été
condamnées qu'on recherche attention à
ne pas tout mélanger ça c'est le premier
point de prudence si ensuite il s'agit
de savoir et d'avoir un fichier pour
savoir à quelle période telle ou telle
personne devait repartir dans son pays
d'origine oui c'est nécessaire car
paradoxalement en France on laisse
rentrer les gens on donne des titres de
séjour ou des visas mais on ne vérifie
jamais à l'expiration de leur titre de
séjour s'ils sont encore sur le
territoire ou s'ils sont rentrés l'autre
volet du texte présenté par Olivier du
socle visa améliorer l'insertion
professionnelle des travailleurs
immigrés le ministre du Travail plaide
entre autres pour la création d'un titre
séjour métier en tension pour recruter
dans les secteurs touchés par des
pénuries de main d'oeuvre autre mesure
avancées supprimer le délai de carence
de 6 mois qui empêche les demandeurs
d'asile de travailler sur le territoire
une mesure que salue le socialiste
Jean-Pierre Sueur des gens qui sont
demandeurs d'asile et bien le temps
qu'ils obtiennent de statut de demandeur
d'asile
des mois et des mois et des mois se
passent parce que il faut que les
instances examinent le dossier statut et
pendant des mois on ne peut pas les
expulser puisqu'ils sont demandeurs
d'asile donc il faut qu'il reste en
France et ne peuvent pas travailler
c'est une situation absolument
inextricable donc si on peut aller dans
une solution humaine à cet égard je
dirais que c'est positif ce projet de
loi le 29e depuis 1980 devrait être
présenté au Parlement au premier
semestre 2023 je vous présente tout de
suite mes invités Dominique Verrien
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice
Union centriste de l'Yonne et membre de
la commission des lois au Sénat
Pierre-Henri bonsoir président de France
fraternité ancien président de France
Terre d'Asile Didier lesquimmonsoir vous
êtes le directeur général de l'Office
français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration et Guillaume Daret que je
souhaite accueillir dans cette émission
bonsoir électoraliste politique français
nous prête pour pour une soirée merci
Guillaume d'être avec
le moment du mercato allez je commence
avec le premier volet on va dire de ce
de cette proposition de ce projet de loi
le ce titre de séjour métier en tension
de rien peut-être déjà une position
politique est-ce que vous y êtes
favorable alors personnellement j'y suis
favorable parce que c'est une chose qui
est demandée par nos entreprises
ce que dénonçait jean-Pierre Sueur est
tout à fait juste nous avons sur le
territoire des demandeurs d'asile qui ne
demandent qu'à travailler d'ailleurs
pour pouvoir être autonome et continuer
à vivre nous avons en face des
entreprises qui ne demandent qu'à les
embaucher parce que réellement alors je
crois que c'est 7 et demi le taux de
chômage en France mais chez nous dans
l'Yonne c'est 6% et il ne trouve pas et
ils ont là des gens qui seraient prêt à
venir travailler et ne peuvent pas les
embaucher et donc je sais que plusieurs
entreprises m'ont déjà demandé
d'intervenir auprès du préfet pour voir
si on pouvait faciliter les choses donc
objectivement ça répond à une vraie
demande par ailleurs on a vu plusieurs
cas de d'apprenti par exemple qui sont
que l'on prend donc en charge pour leur
apprentissage qui sont souvent pour nous
c'est dans la restauration et à 18 ans
on leur dit ah bah non désolé maintenant
vous avez 18 ans vous devez repartir
alors qu'on a investi sur leur formation
qu'il rendent réellement un service
qu'en face il y a pas si on avait tant
de personnes que ça qui c'est nous
cherchait à travailler dans ces
domaines-là ma foi pourquoi pas mais là
objectivement ce sont vraiment des
métiers sous tension donc pourquoi pas
par contre en contrepartie si on fait ça
il faut non seulement régulariser mais
faire la chasse à tous les patrons qui
aujourd'hui exploitent profitent d'avoir
des gens sans papiers pour pouvoir les
sous-payer et donc régulariser ce qui
permettrait aussi d'avoir une
concurrence saine d'ailleurs
Pierre-Henri ça peut être un argument
pour pour cette aspect de la loi
effectivement
on sera dans on sera plus dans cette
zone grise qui permet à certains patrons
on a dit bien dit certains de d'en
profiter donc est-ce que vous
régularisation souhaitable finalement le
principe de réalité on pourrait dire
d'abord je vous fais remarquer une chose
c'est que nous n'avons pas les détails
véritables du projet de loi et que nous
ne savons pas si ce titre en tension des
métiers en tension pour
les étrangers en situation et régulière
sera un titre qui sera renouvelable s'il
est pour une durée précise s'il donnera
droit à une vie familiale normale etc
donc là nous sommes dans la mise en
place du décor et je vérifie pardon de
définir ce que sont les métiers en
tension parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a 95%
des patrons qui disent on n'arrive pas à
embaucher donc oui absolument on sait
même si on sait ce que où se situe les
métiers ont en surpi j'ajoute quand même
un élément nous avons une particularité
dans ce pays c'est de faire une loi sur
à peu près tous les 20 mois
29e loi depuis 1986
que celle-ci est absolument
indispensable pour le bien-être du pays
et sans jamais évaluer la précédente en
réalité des lois nous en avons nous
avons un processus qui aujourd'hui
permet normalement de procéder à la
régularisation d'un certain nombre de
personnes en situation irrégulière il
s'agit pas des demandeurs d'asile les
demandeurs d'asile il y a une directive
européenne qui dit très clairement que
au-delà de 9 mois normalement les
préfectures peuvent accorder des
dérogations pour travailler il s'agit
des personnes qui sont en situation
irrégulière qui souvent se sont vues
délivrer des occultés parce que le qtf
c'est obligation de quitter le
territoire français je rappelle oui
absolument c'est un acte administratif
banalise dans les préfectures en
distribue ça comme les petits pains et
et évidemment on se pose la question
derrière comment se fait-il que les au
qtf ne sont pas exécutés alors c'est lié
mais on y viendra enfin un vrai chapitre
sur les locuteurs dans un instant je
vais vous donner la parole Didier leski
sur sur ce alors évidemment vous allez
pas pouvoir répondre à ma question je
pense quand on parle d'immigration
régulière irrégulière sur compliqué
d'avoir des chiffres mais ça pourrait
concerner combien de personnes cette
mesure écoutez je n'en sais rien c'est
normal d'abord parce que comme Pierre
Henri vient de le dire il faut d'abord
déterminer quels sont les métiers en
tension et c'est un travail qui est fait
par le ministère du Travail déjà depuis
plusieurs années dans le l'entretien qui
est donné par le ministre du Travail il
dit que il vend en discuter avec les
partenaires sociaux il faut voir
exactement quels sont ces métiers s'ils
peuvent correspondre ou pas aux
personnes qui sont présentes sur le
territoire souvent les métiers en
tension sont des métiers de de grande
qualification il n'y a pas que des
métiers qui supposent simplement une
formation de base et pour lesquelles on
puisse assez facilement le le métier je
rajoute que tous les ans plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de visa de travail
sont donnés à des personnes pour venir
en France en particulier
30-35000 ça dépend des années en
particulier dans l'informatique en
particulier venant d'un certain nombre
de pays du Maghreb et donc la situation
est en plus compliquée par deux choses
qu'il ne faut pas oublier d'abord nous
avons donné ces dernières années ces
cinq dernières années un titre dit
humanitaire c'est un type de réfugiés ou
de protection après de 200 000 personnes
dont beaucoup sont ici et demandent à
travailler et dont il faut les amener à
être formés pour remplir justement les
métiers pour lesquels on aurait des
besoins et puis la deuxième chose c'est
que nous avons une partie de ceux qui
viennent et qui peuvent être aussi dans
le clandestinité qui ne parlent pas le
français et c'est le prérequis minimal
souvent qui est demandé par les
employeurs mais c'est vrai pour
clandestine c'est vrai aussi pour des
tas de jeunes qui sont dans des
quartiers qui sont sortis du système
scolaire avec très peu de formation et
que nous avons du mal à prendre en
charge pour les amener vers des métiers
parce qu'il y a un problème aussi d'être
activité et je rajoute que dans les
problèmes d'attractivité il y a les
lieux où on peut travailler et la
question du logement et le ministre du
Travail dans son entretien dit il faut
aussi que les patrons ceux qui veulent
embaucher
participent aussi de l'effort en ce qui
concerne le logement ce n'est pas simple
ça existait une certaine époque ça pas
toujours été probant puisque je rappelle
que dans les années 60 et bien les
patrons avaient une obligation de de
logement pas dans des conditions optimum
mais et donc il y a tout ça à réfléchir
mais bien évidemment il faut régulariser
et et la circulaire qu'on appelle Valls
de 2012 permet déjà de régulariser
suite un peu la même chose ou en tout
cas la règlement qui me permettait par
moment il peut y avoir sur le site c'est
là où il passer par les employeurs par
contre oui
gouvernement ne demande pas une promesse
d'embauche pour délivrer un titre de
séjour donc en réalité le texte il
existe déjà les métiers en tension on
les connaît dans le secteur du bâtiment
de la sécurité dans le secteur de la
santé qui comme le dit Didier leski
demande aussi un certain nombre de
qualifications donc voilà mais moi ce
qui m'interroge véritablement c'est la
nature du titre de séjour qui sera
délivré parce que attention quand je dis
on plante le décor bien entendu que on
voit bien la tentation de Gérald
Darmanin et du gouvernement c'est d'un
côté on donne un titre de séjour pour
des personnes qui de toute façon
accèdent
malgré tout ce que l'on dit à la
régularisation 30 000 par an aujourd'hui
un peu près et puis de l'autre on va
pourrir la vie des étrangers qui sont
dans une oculteur ça va promettre un
débat extrêmement compliqué
effectivement Guillaume
pour l'instant par le ministère de
l'Intérieur et auquel l'entourage le
général Darmanin pour l'instant c'est
pas répondre c'est qu'il évoque dans
l'interview avec Olivier du sol
peut-être des personnes qui sont déjà
présentes sur le territoire français
donc est-ce que ça veut dire que ça met
fin à un potentiel projet de quota
d'immigration du travail qui est parfois
évoqué dans le débat politique en disant
on doit faire clairement
tous les ans un débat et savoir combien
de personnes vont venir chaque année
combien de personnes en famille quand on
pose la question au ministère de
l'Intérieur en disant aujourd'hui est-ce
que ça veut dire que ce titre de travail
finalement clos si j'ose dire le débat
qui revient régulièrement sur le devant
de la scène des quotas de travail pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de réponse sur ce
plan-là un mot là-dessus je vous redonne
la parole juste après qui ont des quotas
d'abord sont des pays d'abord qui ont
des frontières précises on parle souvent
du Canada et le Canada vient d'annoncer
que il est prêt à accueillir peut-être
500 000 personnes pour ses besoins de
main d'oeuvre c'est difficile Canada est
un pays où il y a la mer des deux côtés
il y a le froid il y a les États-Unis en
bas la densité de population qui est
bien bonne et la deuxième chose c'est
que
ça veut dire que c'est même si c'est
dangereux de traverser la Méditerranée
ça reste beaucoup plus simple que
traverser le Pacifique ou l'Atlantique
on a bien joué donc la question de
comment on garde ses frontières et qui
rentrent et qui ne rentrent pas et
beaucoup plus même si c'est pas
complètement avéré mais c'est beaucoup
plus simple pour le Canada que pour des
pays européens mais la deuxième chose
c'est que ce que appelle des quotas
c'est des qualités des personnes
c'est-à-dire vous parlez le français
l'anglais vous avez des diplômes et à ce
moment-là on vous choisit et nous notre
problème il est de 2 ordres il y a une
partie de ceux qui arrivent et qui n'ont
pas ces qualifications minimum et puis
il y a les demandeurs d'asile qu'on a
accueilli et puis ceux qui ont été
déboutés et ceux qui ont été déboutés
constitués au bout d'un certain moment
et bien ceux qui sont sortis de ces
jours et pour lesquels il y a une
discussion sans doute à avoir j'ai
remarqué que le ministre de l'Intérieur
parle des Afghans en particulier c'est
un vrai sujet et dans les Afghans il y a
ceux qui ce qu'on appelle les Dublin
c'est-à-dire qui ont été déboutés dans
d'autres pays ou qui sont passés par
d'autres pays et dont on sait peu ouprou
qui tourne en Europe depuis plusieurs
années et là la question c'est de savoir
comment on les prend en charge alors on
va écouter tout de suite une réaction de
de Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur l'intérieur il classe on l'a
vu mais sous forme de Verbatim dans le
sujet de Jonathan je voulais qu'on
l'écoute il classe les immigrés en deux
catégories j'ai résumé les choses dans
le journal Le Monde en disant que nous
devions être désormais gentil avec les
gentils c'est avec les étrangers qui
veulent travailler en France respecter
nos règles parler notre langue être
amoureux notre drapeau et puis s'ils
font des enfants qui le viennent nourrir
la longue corde de ceux qui ont eu comme
moi des grands-parents immigrés qui sont
venus en France pour travailler
courageusement et être méchant avec les
méchant c'est à dire que nous devons ne
pas accepter que quelqu'un qui ne veut
pas s'intégrer qui ne respecte pas nos
règles qui commet des actes de
délinquance ne doit pas rester sur le
sol national Dominique Verrien est-ce
que avec ce cette sémantique on va dire
on est un peu dans la simplification du
du message politique c'est pas nouveau
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on y assiste
ou est-ce que finalement il y a une
réalité aussi politique ou même
idéologique assumée par le ministre
alors je pense qu'on est effectivement
dans la simplification mais cela dit je
crois que
si on veut que être respecté il faut que
quand on donne une punition elle soit
appliquée d'une façon générale au niveau
de la justice et c'est souvent le
problème c'est quand la peine n'est pas
appliquée et là on le voit bien sur les
eaux qtf comme vous le disiez c'est
distribué comme des petits pains
peut-être qu'il vaut mieux essayer
d'être dans distribuer moins mais par
contre quand on ne distribue de les
faire vraiment respecter et de suivre
d'où ce suivi effectivement des gens qui
rentrent qui sortent avec ce fichier
particulier mais effectivement ça sert à
rien d'essayer de distribuer des peines
qu'on ne saura jamais faire respecter
parce que du coup c'est l'État qui n'est
plus respecté il y a aussi une dimension
vous entendez parler finalement de des
quotas et des immigrés qu'on va choisir
en fonction de leur niveau d'études de
leurs qualification etc si on se place
de l'autre côté de la du côté du pays
d'origine est-ce qu'on les pille d'une
certaine façon mais bien évidemment
c'est une c'est un vrai sujet en
particulier on peut pas occulter ça dans
le goût particulier quand on parle des
médecins je veux dire on est dans une
situation là qui est sans doute une
facilité pour nous mais bien sûr on a
besoin de ces médecins mais c'est une
facilité parce que je rappelle que le
tiers des médecins forment tous les ans
en Algérie quitte l'Algérie et beaucoup
vers la France mais aujourd'hui il y a
d'autres débouchés pour ces médecins ils
savent appauvrit mais c'est là où il y a
une difficulté c'est là où il y a une
difficulté parce que dans ces pays il y
a des forces politiques qui nous
expliquent que la France continue à voir
une une politique néocoloniale ou
post-coloniale et qui affaiblit ces pays
et c'est pour ça qu'il y a un équilibre
à trouver et on peut pas avoir d'un côté
un numerus clausus qui empêche des
résidents ici et des jeunes résidents
ici d'accéder aux études de médecine et
de l'autre côté
faire en sorte que les pays qui ont payé
la formation de ces médecins les phases
venir ici pour travailler et parfois un
tarif qui est inférieur à celui des
médecins titulaires oui je reviens moi
sur la pensée binaire du du ministre de
à laquelle on est assez habitué sur un
sujet pourtant extrêmement complexe je
rappelle que le ministre de l'Intérieur
lui-même il y a quelques semaines
chiffrées à près de 700 000 le nombre de
personnes en situation irrégulière sur
le territoire national et donc à moins
d'imaginer des convois
chemin de fer avion etc on va pas
renvoyer les 700 000 personnes il y a un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont sur
le territoire qui sont là depuis
longtemps avec des familles des familles
monoparentales aucun gouvernement
démocratique n'ira les chercher un outil
matin pour les remettre dans un avion
donc à partir de ce moment-là la
question politique c'est sale de la
régularisation gros mots évidemment dès
que vous parlez de titres
évidemment que personne n'a voulu
l'employer et j'ai eu entendu évidemment
la réaction des droit sur cette question
alors on a un certain nombre de
personnes qui aujourd'hui travaillent
déjà dans des entreprises ont exerce des
métiers absolument indispensables dans
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques dans le
secteur de la santé qui ont été en
première ligne et qu'il faut
effectivement avoir le courage de
régulariser maintenant quand l'étranger
représente un danger immédiat documenté
pour l'ordre public qu'il souhaite
éloigner mais ça ne va poser de problème
à personne la vraie question c'est
comment on fait aujourd'hui pour régler
ce problème de 700 000 personnes qui
sont sur le territoire national c'est
les chiffres de Gérald Darmanin les
chiffres de l'aide médicale d'État eux
disent environ 400 000 peu importe
comment fait-on de manière pragmatique
pour régler ce problème sans faire de la
surenchère sur une population qui est
une cible toute désignée elle est une
analyse politique on va dire sur ce
débat avec vous Guillaume d'Aret je le
disais moi en titre c'est le logiciel
macroniste appliqué à l'immigration ah
oui ça se voit même dans la mise en
scène de l'image de nos feux la photo de
l'interview avec nos confrères du monde
effectivement où on voit finalement les
deux lignes du gouvernement avec deux
personnalité qui incarnent ce sont en
même temps politique d'un côté le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
proche de Nicolas Sarkozy qui vient de
la droite de l'autre Olivier du soft qui
lui vient du Parti socialiste et censé
incarner une ligne plus sociale au
ministère du Travail et puis c'est
l'incarnation du macronisme aussi quand
on le voit dans la ligne politique de ce
qui est avancé parce que ce titre de
séjour dont on parle au titre
effectivement de personnes qui
travailleraient dans des métiers en
tension ça répond en réalité à une
demande politique qui remonte depuis
plusieurs semaines au sein de la
majorité au sein même de ministres qui
viennent de la gauche et qui me disaient
qu'ils ont fermenter à Matignon au
président de la République
qui avait une réalité économique qui
s'imposait et qu'il fallait régulariser
ça le terme est bien employé régularisé
par des ministres de gauche qui ne le
prononcent peut-être pas publiquement
mais régulariser un certain nombre de
travailleurs et très concrètement c'est
ce qu'on voit au quotidien Aujourd'hui
cette ligne de gauche et en même temps
cette ligne de droite parce que vous
avez tous entendu Emmanuel Macron la
semaine dernière je vais faire un petit
peu de pub pour ma maison sur France 2
quand même temps fait de la séduction à
droite aussi et qui a dit qu'il fallait
être plus dur sur l'immigration qu'il
fallait moins d'immigrer en France moi
en tout cas d'immigrés qui viendrait au
quotidien en France donc c'est aussi un
outil de séduction et comme toujours ça
va être la difficulté de tenir ces deux
lignes est-ce que ça peut être
politiquement payant alors ça peut
paraître habile mais dommage je pense
que c'est quand même politiquement
risqué c'est politiquement risqué parce
que comme souvent avec Emmanuel Macron
le risque dû en même temps c'est de
donner le sentiment finalement au final
de ne pas faire de choix et donc de nous
contenter personne là où on pensait
satisfaire tout le monde on voit
clairement d'ailleurs que c'est ce qui
se passe depuis ce matin c'est à dire
que là où on pensait séduire la droite
et bien personne à droite n’applaudit
tout ce cri finalement je cite à une
forme de régularisation massive et puis
à gauche on estime soit que ça va pas
assez loin soit pour une partie de la
France insoumise je cite que Gérald
Darmanin court finalement après le
rassemblement national c'est
politiquement risqué aussi Thomas parce
qu'au-delà de la photo dont on parlait
tout à l'heure entre Olivier de choc des
Gérald darmain qui est-ce qu'on voit
partout concrètement depuis ce matin et
qu'on entend à la radio c'est régénéral
Darmanin qui médiatiquement écrase tout
et donc la balance elle penche quand
même plus politiquement du côté du
ministère de l'Intérieur et puis c'est
politiquement risqué enfin je trouve
parce que malheureusement une nouvelle
fois ce débat sur l'immigration risque
de se trouver l'otage des débats
politiques de la course par exemple à la
présidence des républicains personne
d'ici un mois ne dira évidemment qu'il
soutient ce projet parmi les trois
candidats on entendait aussi Bruno
retaillod le sénateur il y a il y a
quelques minutes sur votre antenne
personne ne le dira à droite
otage aussi de la course au leadership
au sein de la nuque entre les
communistes la France insoumise le parti
spécialiste et donc ça s'annonce
extrêmement compliqué pour le
gouvernement de bâtir cette majorité et
bien à laquelle finalement il est
contraint en permanence on voit des
d'essayer de construire une fois sur un
texte une fois sur un autre et ça
s'annonce très compliqué effectivement
ça s'annonce compliqué pour apporter de
l'eau à votre démonstration de réaction
d'abord ce tweet signé Julien Oudoul
député rassemblement national de l'Yonne
des dizaines de milliers de migrants
vont se déclarer aide-soignant cuisinier
couvreur pour ensuite disparaître dans
la nature au frais des contribuables
français le projet de loi immigration se
présente comme un accélérateur de
submersion migratoire stop et puis autre
réaction celle d'érections des
Alpes-Maritimes candidat à la présidence
elle aéron l’écoute on n'arrive pas à
expulser les personnes qui subissent une
au qtf qui sont en situation irrégulière
donc
ID géniale trouver par les deux
ministres on va régulariser des
étrangers en situation irrégulière
entrer illégalement sur le territoire au
motif qu'il pourrait pourvoir des
métiers en tension voilà donc c'est une
forme de supercherie pour aller une
nouvelle fois vers une régularisation
Dominique verrier peut-être une réaction
là est-ce que est-ce que finalement avec
le constat que on est en train de faire
les uns les autres il y a pas une forme
de d'hypocrisie notamment dans la bouche
d'un ériki
mais il faut regarder
de face d'une même pièce d'un côté il y
a effectivement beaucoup d'immigrés qui
travaillent et qui aujourd'hui de toute
façon ne serait pas remplacé par
d'autres parce que il y a personne pour
prendre cette place et cela il vaudrait
mieux pour le coup réellement les
régulariser parce que ça voudrait dire
qu'il paye des charges et qui paye nos
retraites et finalement ça ferait
beaucoup mieux fonctionner la machine
aussi plutôt que de les avoir cachés et
puis ça obligerait des patrons à
régulariser pour ceux qui sont plutôt
des patrons voyous mais il est vrai que
parallèlement moi j'ai passé une nuit
dans le commissariat du 18e quand on
tourne dans le 18e arrondissement et
qu'on va Porte de la Chapelle là on se
dit
voilà on ne vit pas la même chose que
quand on vit dans le 5e arrondissement
clairement et quand on voit les migrants
qui dort qui occupent déjà
dont on comprend qu'ils sont là de toute
façon la police ne fera rien il faut
bien qu'il soit à l'abri ils sont sous
le métro etc pas dans le 18e pour le
coup dans le 18e mais Porte de la
Chapelle effectivement il les pousse
pour éviter que les les au niveau du
crack il s'installe et c'est vrai que
objectivement bah oui mais sauf que
c'est pas le problème c'est quand on dit
c'est un autre sujet
la panache des étrangers ce serait quand
on est Porte de la Chapelle
objectivement on n'a pas du tout la même
impression et en tout mais et moi qui
rentre à pied du Sénat j'ai aucun
problème en rentrant à pied du Sénat
j'avoue que je rentrerai pas à pied
Porte de la Chapelle chez moi donc et
c'est parce que il y a justement ces
deux visions là et il faut réussir à
régler le problème des gens de la Porte
de la Chapelle tout en
étant conscient que il y a aussi des
étrangers et c'est une majorité qui
travaille et qui aujourd'hui emploient
des emplois que de toute façon personne
ne prendrait et que cela on a intérêt à
les régulariser à faire qui rentre dans
un système où il paierait des charges et
il cotiserait pour notre retraite mais
il faut pas dissocier parce que après on
peut pas faire d'angélisme ni
effectivement dire que l'immigration ça
n'est que la porte de la chapelle mais
on peut pas la nier non plus les deux
existent Didier leski quand vous
entendez le RN parler de submersion
migratoire
voilà que disent les chiffres tiens
depuis 10 ans
il y a un quelconque sens derrière une
salle il y a pas de submersion
migratoire maintenant l'Europe fait
partie des continents les plus ouverts à
l'immigration et en particulier
l'immigration légale liée pour ce qui
concerne la France le regroupement
familial c'est-à-dire des personnes qui
ont un droit à acquis au séjour mais
l'Europe est un pays de la diversité et
cette diversité comme l'Amérique du Nord
est liée à à l'immigration et c'est moi
le cas dans d'autres grands pays ou dans
d'autres continents et même dans des
pays de de l'OCDE il faut pas
sous-estimer le sujet de l'immigration
anti dans beaucoup de pays du monde
même les Etats-Unis par exemple qui sont
construits sur l'immigration sont des
sujets politiques extrêmement prégnants
il est fort probable que le basculement
de nouveau vers les républicains seront
en grande partie liées au sujet de de
l'immigration et on voit dans tous les
pays d'Europe actuellement une angoisse
du côté d'une partie de la population
parce que les migration quand elle n'est
pas organisée et légale et et même
parfois quand elle est la projection du
chaos du monde et ce chaos du monde et
bien il y a des tas de raisons pour
lesquelles il peut angoisser une partie
de la population je rajoute en ce qui
nous concerne parce que nous avons des
liens historiques et passer avec un
certain nombre de pays ce chaos est
aussi pour ceux qui ont un peu de
mémoire le reflet de l'échec de la
décolonisation au sens où ces pays n'ont
pas été dirigés c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire par des personnes qui ont été
particulièrement attentives au devenir
de leur population alors scolarisation à
la constitution d'un bien-être et donc
il y a une certaine angoisse et ne pas
la prise en charge peut nous amener
effectivement à des excès comme celui
que vous venez de citer mais vous avez
d'autres pays où de manière peut-être
parfois brutale ou avec des valeurs
qu'on ne partage pas peut-être tout à
fait bien prennent en charge ces
questions et du coup arrive à réduire le
score de l'extrême droite on voit les
élections Danemark par exemple qui ont
eu lieu il y a hier avant-hier c'est un
des arguments d'ailleurs qu'utilise pas
cet extrait là qui était diffusé mais
Gérald darmin qui dit s'il n'y avait
plus de problèmes d'immigration en
France il n'y aurait plus de
rassemblement national c'est son
argument politique pour dire qu'il faut
regarder comme il le dit les problèmes
en face et vous parliez de l'étranger
ils sont plus dans l'Union européenne
mais on voit quelqu'un qui est
extrêmement ferme et en tout cas
extrêmement dur dans ces mots c'est la
ministre de l'intérieur du Royaume-Uni
qui ces derniers jours je crois à parler
d'invasion migratoires dans son pays il
faut rajouter le fait que tout ça est un
phénomène cumulatif c'est vrai qu'on
parle de 29 lois depuis
1980 c'est-à-dire depuis la loi le
projet de loi bonnet que la gauche avait
arrêter en 1980 mais il y a quand même
un lien entre l'effondrement d'une
partie de notre industrie c'est-à-dire
la difficulté que nous avons eu à
continuer à intégrer les personnes par
le travail et aujourd'hui on a peut-être
la possibilité de renouer avec ça parce
que justement on a des besoins de main
d'oeuvre et que le travail a été pendant
longtemps une manière d'intégrer
positivement c'est pas toujours été
facile mais en tout cas d'avoir une
dynamique de citoyenneté sociale avec ce
qu'on appelait un mouvement ouvrier qui
prenait en charge ces questions ça a été
le cas dans les années 60-70
rappelez-vous même qu'au début des
années 70 le l'immigrant algérien était
vécu comme l'immigrant positif parce que
il était pris en charge il avait
participé à la construction de bataille
politique qui marquait notre histoire
c'est la grève de 1947 à Renault par
exemple elle a été faite en grande
partie par des ouvriers algériens qui
étaient du côté de messaliach mais
c'était une époque aussi où en Algérie
la question de l'islamisme était moins
présent le regard sur l'immigration peut
changer c'est ce que vous êtes en train
de nous dire Pierre-Henri vous dit
intervenir oui je voulais dire qu'il
fallait aussi en matière de migration
regardez ce qui se fait dans les pays
voisins et notamment
chez notre voisin allemand
les Allemands la coalition qui est au
pouvoir ont adopté un programme très
clair sur cette question avec un certain
nombre de régularisations ça a été posé
sur la table avant les élections ils ont
été portés au pouvoir et puis sur la
fameuse question des aucutf je vous
rappelle que en Allemagne il y a deux
fois moins docuf délivré qu'en France et
pourtant vous avez une population
étrangère qui est plus importante en
Allemagne qu'en France
proportionnellement au reste de la
population et ces auditeurs elles
simplement un peu plus ciblé
c’est-à-dire qu’on regarde auparavant
quelle est la situation de la personne
au regard du séjour de sa famille de son
parcours et donc du coup vous avez un
taux d'exécution des auqtf qui est à 53%
quand nous nous sommes à 10%. donc si on
commençait s'il législateur commencez
d'abord par se dire
comment je mets en adéquation la loi
avec les moyens de l'administration
ça serait déjà pas mal parce que en fait
l'administration n'a aucun moyen
aujourd'hui de suivre on va y revenir
sur ces
occultés obligations de quitter le
territoire français mais je voudrais
boucler le chapitre sur le destin
politique de ce texte grâce à quand un
cas de mec qui nous rejoint tout de
suite bonsoir Quentin parce que on l'a
un peu évoqué mais c'est intéressant de
rentrer vraiment dans le détail le
gouvernement qui fait un appel du pied à
la droite sénatoriale en reprenant tout
ou partie d'un rapport sénatorial qui
date du printemps dernier c'est
exactement de mai dernier effectivement
qui venait de François Noel buffet le
président LR de la commission des Lois
du Sénat on avait retrouvé certaines
pistes dans ce rapport comme cette idée
de simplification par exemple des
procédures de recours mais la droite on
se dit qu'elle pourrait être encore plus
favorable au texte du Gouvernement qui
va venir notamment sur l'immigration
choisie en fonction des secteurs
d'activité on a donc posé la question à
François noelbuffet écoutez sa réponse
d'abord je suis convaincu sur le
principe de l'immigration choisie
naturellement ça veut dire qu'il y a des
choix des priorités choisir
l'immigration économique comme une
priorité est une bonne chose ce sera
nouveau tant mieux encore faut-il se
mettre d'accord sur la notion d'économie
je pense que c'est sur une immigration
du travail qualifiée soit de haut niveau
soit d'un niveau plus modeste mais en
tous les cas qualifiés qui nous
permettent de répondre effectivement à
ces métiers en tension que sur le
bâtiment travaux publics la restauration
les l'aide à domicile souvent mais
également
l'hôtellerie c'est très bien en tant que
tel la question maintenant est de savoir
dans quelle mesure dans quel volume dans
quels critères voilà ça c'est la réponse
donc sur le fond des arguments sur un
versant beaucoup plus politique on a vu
la réaction de Bruno Retailleau à notre
micro tout à l'heure il a d'ailleurs
fait un communiqué au passage je voulais
vous le montrer parce que les mots sont
forts sur cette question des titres des
séjours les titres de séjour des métiers
il parle d'une forme de lâcheté de la
part du gouvernement c'est ce qu'il a
publié ce soir écoutez sa réaction à
notre micro
c'est certainement pas en inscrivant sur
un fichier des personnes recherchées que
on aura demain des résultats en revanche
en revanche je le dis solennellement
aujourd'hui je pense que le projet tel
qui se dessine ce sera encore plus
d'immigration puisque on se propose
régulariser avec des titres de séjour
pour le travail sur des métiers en
tension mais vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
toute la France est une zone
géographique concernée par des métiers
en tension et puis maintenant tous les
métiers tous les métiers sont en tension
donc c'est une ouverture des vins de
même que si demain pour celles et ceux
qui sont candidats au droit d'asile on
leur dit vous pouvez travailler ça veut
dire simplement que si n'obtiennent pas
leurs droits d'asile ils pourront rester
au titre d'un séjour pour le travail
donc c'est bien plus d'immigration au
bout du compte voilà Bruno Retailleau un
chef de file dessinateur est là
également candidat à la présidence du
parti LR dans les prochaines semaines en
tout cas on verra début janvier que
l'examen de ce texte sera crucial au
Sénat surtout si et bien il y a eu le
gouvernement veut faire passer le texte
et qui ne dispose plus du et bien du
fusil à un coup car 49 travail faudra
alors trouver un accord avec la droite
sénatoriale Thomas merci Quentin
Guillaume d'arrêt peut-être un mot sur
le ce contexte de l’évoquer rapidement
dans votre chronique tout à l'heure de
de d'élection interne chez elle on peut
avoir le sentiment d'une forme de
surenchère entre les deux favoris et
Bruno Retailleau
comment pourrait-il donner la main à
cette alliance
réclamée d'ailleurs c'était sur France 2
par Emmanuel Macron la semaine dernière
après avoir été aussi rigide pendant
toute la campagne interne vous voyez ce
que je veux dire ce sera compliqué
évidemment d'ici le scrutin de le faire
et ce sera difficile y compris après en
particulier pour Eric justice ici c'est
lui qui l'emporte parce que vous savez
qu'il est soutenu officiellement
d'ailleurs par Laurent Wauquiez qui est
clairement sur une ligne d'indépendance
avec le gouvernement après ce sera
compliqué pour le gouvernement de
construire quelque chose avec Heller sur
cette question là aussi parce qu'au-delà
qui que ce soit qui l'emporte à la tête
du parti les députés qui restent à
l'assemb international aujourd'hui c'est
des auto-entrepreneurs ils ont gagné sur
leur nom ils ne doivent absolument rien
aux partis et donc quand bien même il y
aura une consigne au niveau du parti de
dire on passe un accord avec le
gouvernement sur cette question de
l'immigration il n'est pas certain qu'il
le suivent donc ça s'annonce très
compliqué et c'est pour ça
qu'effectivement Emmanuel Macron sur ce
plan de ce dossier essaye peut-être
davantage de draguer la droite
sénatoriale que les députés de
l'Assemblée alors je il nous reste un
peu moins de 10 minutes on va on va
vraiment passer la fin de ce débat sur
le l'applicabilité ou les conditions
dans lesquelles c'est occupés ces
obligations de quitter le territoire
français sont délivrés d'abord un
chiffre 122000 obligations
signifiée en 2021 Dominique Verrien on
l'a un peu évoqué rapidement et je vois
bien que vous rentriez dans le détail
elles sont presque pas appliquées vous
disiez 10% en France il y a eu un
rapport dans le rapport du scénar dont
on parlait premier semestre 2021 c'était
moins de 6 %. donc c'est quoi c'est là
aussi c'est un leurre sont des préfets
qui se bonne conscience comme vous
l'expliquez ça je pense que ça doit être
donné effectivement de façon automatique
et sans forcément cibler et je crois que
c'est ce que je disais une peine il faut
qu'elle soit respectée et sinon ça sert
à rien de la donner et donc il vaudrait
mieux cibler et écarter vraiment les
personnes qu'on ne veut pas du tout
avoir sur le territoire c'est un peu
l'exemple que je donnais entre celui qui
travaille paisiblement objectivement et
qui rend service à l'hôtel à l'hôtelier
chez qui il travaille et puis celui qui
maintient un réseau de prostitution ou
un réseau de crack objectivement il faut
plutôt mettre la pression sur celui
qu'on veut voir partir et puis faire
comme en Allemagne et mieux trier qui on
veut chasser et qui on veut garder en se
disant d'ailleurs que voilà ce qui
travaille et qui s'intègre c'est une
force et c'est plutôt un avantage pour
nous là encore je reviens sur mes
cotisations et mes retraites c'est pas
complètement anodin le fait que on a
aussi besoin de gens qui qui travaillent
et qui cotisent donc voilà mieux cerner
mieux cibler et mieux renvoyer mais je
vais vous faire sourire dans l'Yonne on
arrive assez bien à renvoyer parce qu'en
fait ce qu'on renvoie le mieux c'est
ceux qui sortent de la prison de la
ville parce que pour le coup on s'est
préparé leur départ quand il sort de la
prison les emmène directement et puis
cela vont quitter le territoire donc
l'idée c'est effectivement faire en
sorte que tous ceux qui sortent de
prison repartent mais mieux cibler et
être plus efficace sur sur ces départs
là Didier lesqui c'estoc là dont on a
tant parlé depuis deux semaines avec la
polémique nous on n'a pas voulu faire de
débats là-dessus sur le nord de la
petite Lola et sur cette part de
récupération politique c'est un vrai
choix éditorial si on essaye calmement
d'analyser ce que c'est pourquoi ça
marche pas comment vous le vous
l'expliquez d'abord il faut dire que on
n'a pas trouvé d'autres moyens de
régulation de l'immigration qu'une forme
de contrainte et donc le qtf c'est une
contrainte la deuxième chose c'est que
la principale difficulté aujourd'hui de
l'obligation qui était le territoire
français dans son exécution c'est ce
qu'on appelle les laisser passer
consulaires et que nous la
caractéristique d'une partie de notre
migration c'est qu'elle vient de pays
qui refuse de livrer de délivrer les
laisser passer consulaires et c'est un
peu différent du reste de l'Allemagne
qui exécute beaucoup vers des anciens
pays de l'Est qui pour certains veulent
absolument rentrer dans l'Union
européenne donc ce sont les bons élèves
de la délivrance des laisser passer
consulaires du reste en ce qui concerne
la France beaucoup de nos laissés passer
consulaires et bien viennent de pays
comme l'Albanie ou la Géorgie est
beaucoup de difficultés viennent de pays
comme l'Algérie la Tunisie le Maroc d'où
la pression qui a été exercée sur les
visas qui est pas une pression absurde
puisque avant les grandes les vagues
importantes de demandeurs d'asile les
chercheurs ont montré sur la base des
précédentes opérations des
régularisations que beaucoup de ceux qui
étaient qui avaient été régularisés
étaient passés
sans papier je vais sans titre de séjour
mais était rentré à partir d'un visa
tourisme et c'est du reste quelque chose
qui est important de comprendre parce
que si on veut par exemple la boutir à
ce qu'on appelait une idée d'une
migration circulaire et bien il faut que
les personnes qui obtiennent un visa de
court séjour le respect aussi non on se
retrouve de nouveau dans quelque chose
qui est de l'attention et voilà la
difficulté mais le président de la
République a avancé quelque chose qui
est qui peut-être une une porte je
dirais de d'efficacité c'est de lier une
partie de l'aide au développement
avec la délivrance des laisser passer
consulaires par exemple ce que font les
Italiens avec la Tunisie les italiens
arrivent à renvoyer beaucoup plus de
Tunisiens avec même un aéroport dédié
pour cela qui est l'aéroport du côté
dammamet parce que il lit cela
l'Allemagne l'affaire à un moment donné
même pour l'Afghanistan quand il
s'agissait de renvoyer des des personnes
nous culturellement nous avons des
administrations qui sont un peu séparées
et ce qu'a voulu impulser le président
de la République c'est de dire on peut
pas réfléchir à la question de l'aide au
développement sans avoir un partenariat
efficace sur la sur la gestion des des
reconduites parce que cette non gestion
des reconduites elle va toucher des
personnes qui mériteraient d'avoir un
visa pour venir en France et à qui on
refuse de visa parce que justement il y
a pas une collaboration totale je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure l'une des phrases
prononcées par le ministre de
l'Intérieur à premier jour c'est qu'il
souhaite rendre la vie impossible aux
étrangers soumis à cette obligation de
quitter le territoire
finalement il n'a même pas besoin
d'attendre le vote de la loi dont on
parle de plus début de ce débat il a des
outils réglementaires il les a rappelé
aujourd'hui on l'écoute vous avez vu que
j'ai pris notamment deux dispositions ne
sont pas législatives qui vont être
mises en place dès la fin de semaine à
la demande du Président de la République
inscrire toutes les personnes qui sont
sans papier qui doivent quitter tel État
national dans les fichiers de police
pour qu'évidemment on puisse à chaque
fois constater leur départ ou permettre
leur départ c'est vraiment une
instruction extrêmement importante et
tout à fait nouvelle qui va nous aider
fortement à lutter contre l'immigration
irrégulière et la deuxième c'est que les
personnes qui sont irrégulièrement sur
le territoire national ne peuvent pas
bénéficier d'allocations sociales ou
d'un logement social puisque la
difficulté d'aujourd'hui c'est que les
préfectures ne parlaient pas soit au
bailleur sociaux soit au cas
d'allocations familiales par exemple
lorsque qu'elles avaient
mis fin à la séjour régulier d'une
personne
Guillaume Darré ça a pas forcément plus
l'aile gauche de la macronie la semaine
dernière quand pour la première fois
effectivement il a dit qu'il fallait
rendre impossible la vie ces personnes
qui sont sous UTF parce que dès le début
notamment par exemple sachahoulier qui
est le président de la commission des
lois à l'Assemblée a dit attention il y
a deux catégories effectivement de
personnes il y a ceux effectivement qui
pourrissent la vie d'une partie des
habitants en France cela effectivement
il faut leur rendre la vie impossible
mais les autres qui travaillent quand on
regarde les mots qu'employés d'ailleurs
certains députés de gauche voir venant
de la gauche qui appartiennent à la
majorité on n'est pas loin de ce qui a
finalement dans dans l'interview
aujourd'hui Gérald Darmanin qui essaie
de tenir tant bien que mal c'est de
ligne dont on parlait dont on parlait
tout à l'heure donc clairement quand le
ministre de l'Intérieur dit on va
essayer de de pourrir clairement la vie
de ceux qui ne méritent plus d'être sur
le territoire c'est aussi en creux une
façon de répondre à l'aile gauche de la
macronie qui ne voulait pas qu'on mette
tout le monde dans le même panier
Pierre Henry je reprends l'idée
ou le texte qui va rentrer en vigueur
d'après Gérard Darmanin là très vite
puisqu'il dit euh ça va être mis en
place dès la fin de la semaine le fait
de croiser les fichiers des auqtf avec
ceux de la police des CAF ou des
bailleurs sociaux oui alors efficacité
oui oui mais d'abord il y a une fake
news total
les personnes en situation irrégulière
n'ont pas accès au logement social enfin
vraiment ça voilà ce qui dit quand on
lui pose la question c'est qui dit c'est
celle qui aurait bénéficié préalablement
d'un logement social équipe du fait d'un
renouvellement qui n'aboutit pas se
retrouve sous le coup d'une autre qtf et
qui donc reste dans ce logement social
donc il y a quelques cas oui oui il est
possible qu'il y ait quelques cas mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que d'abord
les fichiers ils existent quand la
police vérifie la situation
l'étranger en situation
lors de par exemple de
à la sauvette de contrôle qui peuvent se
faire dans les villes ils savent
exactement quelle est la situation de la
personne encore une fois
400 à 700 000 personnes en situation
irrégulière donc le fichier il faut
aussi avoir les moyens de le traiter et
c'est tout le sens d'un rapport du
Conseil d'État qui dit bon en gros le
législateur pond des lois en permanence
sauf qu'il ne se posent jamais la
question derrière des moyens de
l'administration pour appliquer les lois
je vais vous donner un exemple très
concret sur la délivrance des auqtf nous
parlions tout à l'heure des Afghans les
Afghans les soudaines et les érythréens
les Somaliens il arrive qu'il y en ait
un grand nombre qui soit des bouteilles
de leur demande des îles et qui se voit
de distribuer des aucutés on ne les
reconduit jamais parce que le la
reconduite malheureusement on ne renvoie
personne en Afghanistan Somalie en
érythèques mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
les laisse dans la rue dans la précarité
ou au moins des réseaux commençons par
être pragmatique sur ces sur ces
questions ayons un petit peu de courage
ça fera un peu moins de qtf et sans
doute un certain nombre de personnes qui
se verraient être attribués un titre de
protection temporaire les Allemands font
ça les aux États-Unis ça se fait aussi
c'est pas un truc de gauchiste donc
voilà ça serait bien parfois d'aller
chercher les bonnes pratiques chez nos
voisins allez on termine la si vous
voulez dire un dernier mot peut-être que
c'est ridicule de donner une itef à
quelqu'un dont on sait dès le départ que
de toute façon on peut pas le renvoyer
donc c'est vrai que
pour appliquer
que vous n'imaginez pas renvoyer une
femme afghane en ce moment en
Afghanistan on est bien d'accord bah
voilà donc
à partir de là je pense que il faut
forcément avoir un statut au moins
temporaire qui qui fasse que on se mette
en conformité avec ce qu'on peut faire
ou pas faire
rapide non mais la difficulté c'est
c'est d'arriver à trouver l'équilibre
pour faire en sorte que toute personne
qui arriverait sur le territoire se
trouverait de fait somptuariser parce
que on ne pourrait pas la renvoyer alors
que d'autres pays dans l'Union
européenne le font j'ai pas de ça
personne renvoie que enfin je ne connais
aucun pays européen qui renvoie tout le
monde vers les pays qu'on vient de bien
sûr que non mais la question c'est de
savoir s'il y a le sentiment que des
composent le pied vient de toute façon
rien ne se passera l'appel d'air quoi
pardon l'appel d'air
aucune réforme peut provoquer c'est une
réalité ça ou c'est un fantasme non mais
c'est arrivé mais nous sommes qui fait
appel d'air c'est une question
n'est pas une forteresse l'Europe est un
pays globalement
accueillant comme un continent
globalement accueillant et c'est
particulièrement vrai de la France et
c'est parce que nous sommes un pays
accueillant qu'il faut établir des
règles très précises les appliquer avec
intelligence et faire en sorte de ne pas
donner le sentiment à la majorité de la
population que tout ça ébrouillons et
donc il faut et 2
je ne suis pas certain que ce débat sur
l'immigration tel qu'il se présente sur
la meilleure chose merci politique
moi j'aime bien laisser la parole aux
participants de l'inscription au
fichiers des personnes recherchées c'est
que le ministère de l'Intérieur en
coulisse conseil lui-même que c'est
davantage un outil statistique pour
avoir un état des lieux de qui est sous
occupé F qui n'en n'y est pas qu'un
outil d'efficacité pour la reconduction
qui ne part pas et puis de toute façon à
partir du moment où ça s'appuie sur le
rapport de François Noel buffet il y a
forcément quand même des choses
intelligentes
en tout cas il y a bien un moment où il
faut que je dise que le débat est
terminé et c'est maintenant merci à tous
d'y avoir
participé et à bientôt sur public